[Musique]
radio
foulée de connaître des québécois de
connaître sherbrooke de parler le
français d'avoir des amis il ya quelques
mois à peine cette jeune femme était
isolé du monde elle vivait à kaboul
enfermé chez ses parents sans
possibilité d'étudier ou de travail et
mettrait son téléphone sonne un peu
comme tels facebook et sa masse angel
gurria en france un
bandeau zemeckis à vanuatu
murs elle a 20 ans elle vit maintenant
avec la famille de son mari acmad
arrivée à sherbrooke il ya presque trois
ans
acmad tout comme murs sales et d'origine
hasard à une ethnie largement persécutés
en afghanistan avait laissé un dom duff
comme on le fit on a des autres pour
l'homme c'est pas parce que on a à sarah
en ml on n'est pas de roide à allada les
connais pas ce que veulent les attaques
toujours sur le mandat zara maintenant à
l'abri des persécutions la famille
husseini s'adapte lentement aux réalités
locales
vous mangez un copie mais
ça ça dans les rides
non j'ai pas de routine et on a monté le
potenza chaque année
murs sales assistent à des cours de
français tous les matins et à des
activités d'intégration en après midi
ce jour-là elle participait à une visite
d'un centre de formation professionnelle
[Musique]
il est 15h30 la première moitié de sa
journée est terminée murs sales
s'apprête maintenant à entreprendre la
deuxième à l' usine où elle travaille de
16 heures à minuit
[Musique]
elle a trouvé cet emploi aussitôt
arrivée à sherbrooke bien avant d'avoir
appris à balbutier les mots usines ou
sablage poursuivait dans les journaux la
crise qui se passe en afghanistan va
rapidement nos ressources mais nous ont
suggéré d'aller rencontrer
le centre communautaire afghans dont
personnellement j'ignorais l'existence
dans le contexte actuel de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre les réfugiés afghans
fraîchement arrivé en estrie trouve très
rapidement eu l'emploi ce sont des gens
qui veulent apprendre un métier vivre
nous on ne demande qu à ça d'avoir des
bars des employés qui le fag contenu
n'est pas garant de notre entreprise
merci beaucoup murs elle s'intègre bien
sa nouvelle vie semble pleine de
promesses mais il lui manque une part de
son identité
mark gorton bretagne
mike valade la
base
elle a pu quitter son pays parce qu'elle
allait rejoindre son mari mais les
membres de sa famille comme des dizaines
de milliers d'autres qui ont travaillé
pour les occidentaux sont toujours
coincés en afghanistan et craignent
d'être tué ou normal ça le maillot n'est
seul barrage au front de bullguard
métaux récupérés ou spinoza
faux cul vraiment quelqu'un prendre la
responsabilité même les pays étrangers
juste un nouveau d'accepter des lits
fuji ce résidant de sherbrooke lui même
d'origine afghane s'est donné comme
mission de faciliter le parrainage de
ressortissants étrangers ils déplorent
la lenteur du gouvernement canadien à
accueillir ses compatriotes à un moment
donné même le canada est hyper des
images parce que dépit combien de mois
qui en annonce on annonce en annonce on
voit un minet mais finalement on n'a
même pas arrivé à 4000 il y aurait
quelque chose à faire
c'est d'aider pas mettre les
regroupement familial pour cette
spécialiste de l'accueil des réfugiés le
temps presse pour sauver des vies mais
aussi pour limiter les dégâts
psychologiques faut faire attention
parce que ça peut représenter des
problèmes de santé mentale est d'être
allende des séparations des problèmes d
intégration aussi d'adaptation vos
commentaires en langue haoussa de
moteurs à courant ce mécano madara 10 q
et bat avec pas mois bétadine sonorités
jazz cave chaque mois fait la malle et
nous souhaitons avoir des enfants au
moins trois murs sales pas plus de trois
répond acmad comme les canadiens
ce ne sont pas les projets qui manquent
les murs sales a du mal à envisager
cette nouvelle vie sans ses proches
comme si son exil n'était pas encore
tout à fait aboutie